mais dans les six et demi
c'est à moi qu'on a confié 1 minute non
allez soyons sérieux
bon alors aujourd'hui on va traiter d'un
sujet très délicat lors gas alors j'aime
écouter le célèbre docteur valentin sexe
allogreffe des as qu'ils vendent
je vais demander docteur vous faites
c'est l'organe kaléidoscope non phibel
pardon je vais vous demander de conclure
parce qu'elle est plus que 30 secondes
et bien c'est un sujet qu'on ne doit pas
traiter par de soulagement
je voudrais ajouter unis merci docteur
alors j'espère que ça l'avait tout très
attentive aux conseils de docteur valant
pas il me reste plus que 10 secondes
pour vous dire au revoir et la semaine
prochaine nous allons minutes au top
[Musique]